volkswagen is celebrating the opening of
its new plant envious Nia Poland around
a thousand guests politicians business
leaders as well as staff and union
representatives were on hand as
production of the new crafter model
officially began here some 3,000
employees are expected to produce around
100,000 vehicles a year
that's well VW's on delay eventually
says around two or two-and-a-half years
ago they were searching for a production
location BW commercial vehicles already
had plants in Poland the Caddy's built
here ma N and Scania have factories here
those good experiences led them to build
the new crafter plant here too
VW has already invested around 800
million euros and the new factory 437
state-of-the-art robots ensure that the
highest quality standards are met the
new plant was built in record time just
twenty three months it's an important
building block in what VW has touted as
its new strategic course for light
commercial vehicles says the new crafter
is positioned in a growing segment think
about all the city traffic package
deliveries and so forth when it's many
variants the crafter is one-of-a-kind
starting next year it'll even be offered
with electric drive system tourism I
anything else on the market look
increasingly commercial vans are
offering the kinds of creature comforts
once reserved for passenger cars so the
new crafter has optional electronically
adjustable seats
other options include a new power
steering system and numerous driver
assists and the new crafter is a master
when it comes to individualization lawns
iron-shod says there are 69 body
variants and derivatives various drive
systems front wheel rear wheel and
standard and then there are all the
conversions 70% conversions means that
the vehicle is customized for a specific
purpose whether for a handyman or the
fire department either they do that
themselves
here in Vienna or with partners who are
conversion specialists so most every
vehicle is unique its first year this
thoughts look a newly caught even in the
basic layout of its cargo area the
crafter provides plenty of room for
individuality special rails along the
floors and the walls served to hold
objects in place this allows customers
to reuse fittings like shelves and
cupboards taken from other vehicles
just a few weeks ago the crafter was
named international van of the year 2017
by a jury of 24 journalists from top
European commercial vehicle magazines
from standard to customized versions of
the crafter including flatbed pickups
and emergency vehicles the new plant in
bosch nia will produce them all